Magic, mystery, and mayhem – oh my!
From sentient swords and CIA conspiracies
to warring martial arts academies, the world
of the movie ninja is as vast as it is weird.
For most American audiences, the term "ninja"
summons up a collection of pop culture references
— the long-running Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles franchise and Chris Farley's pratfalls
in Beverly Hills Ninja may be a couple that
come to mind.
For cult movie fans, it may be the avalanche
of interchangeable 80's action movies featuring
a mix of Caucasian and Asian actors tossing
shuriken at bad guys.
"Thank you."
"That's very impressive."
But the earliest movies about ninja long predated
the '80s boom.
Japanese filmmakers first began making movies
about ninja as early as the silent film era.
Many of these early titles centered around
folk tales, like those of Jiraiya and Sarutobi
Sasuke — and yes, these stories directly
inspired the Naruto characters of the same name.
Unfortunately, like the vast majority of silent
movies, very few of these early efforts still exist.
In fact, the 1921 film Jiraiya the Brave is
considered to be the oldest surviving ninja
film, though only 20 minutes of the movie
remain intact.
Today, ninja are seemingly everywhere.
When ninja went worldwide in the 1980s, other
countries started making their own adventures
— including Sweden, Argentina, South Korea
and India.
There are ninja anime, giant monster movies,
comedies, and even "adults-only" films.
Ninja were inescapable in Japanese movie theaters
during the 1950s and 1960s.
The website Vintage Ninja breaks down this
period into distinct types, with one being
the fantasy-fueled efforts.
These ninja were more like wizards, battling
evil sorcerers and giant monsters with a mix
of swordplay and spells.
The 1959 animated ninja film Shonen Sarutobi
Sasuke fits in this vein, as we witness the
titular proto-ninja and his fight against
a lake demon.
Unlike many of its fellow fantasy ninja films,
it saw a theatrical release in the United
States — but strangely, the American version
called Magic Boy removed any references to ninja.
The other ninja films of the '60s boom included
black-and-white historical action-dramas,
fueled by a mix of political intrigue, energetic
camerawork and bloody fight sequences.
Some traits — such as the ninja's superhuman
stealth and their array of unique weapons
— would carry over into the brawny American
cousins of the 1980s.
But films like the stark, psychologically
driven Samurai Spy couldn't be more different
from the action antics in the American Ninja
series.
For many Westerners, their first exposure
to ninja came from the 1967 James Bond film,
You Only Live Twice.
It focuses on a dissolute Bond learning ninjutsu
in Japan to carry out the assassination of
his nemesis, Blofeld.
"The firing power inside my crater is enough
to annihilate a small army.
You can watch it all on TV."
Two real-life martial artists were hired by
the film's producers to lend authenticity
to the ninja sequences.
Judo champion Donn F. Draeger not only trained
Sean Connery in many fighting styles, but
also served as his stunt double.
This wasn't uncommon, as Draeger had previously
served as John Wayne's stunt double in the
1958 film The Barbarian and the Geisha.
The other consultant was Masaaki Hatsumi — recognized
today as a grandmaster of the nine schools
of martial arts — who also appeared in the
movie as an aide to the spy Tiger Tanaka.
Hatsumi later used his training to found a
dojo in Japan, where thousands travel each
year to learn ninjutsu techniques.
By the mid-1970s, ninja had infiltrated American
popular culture.
They appeared on television series, like Kung
Fu and Hawaii Five-0, while Marvel and DC
introduced ninja characters in Judomaster,
Shang-Chi: Master of Kung Fu and the Deadly
Hands of Kung Fu anthology.
However, ninja wouldn't turn up in a Hollywood
movie until 1975's The Killer Elite.
Directed by action auteur Sam Peckinpah, the
movie concerns a pair of undercover agents
for hire, played by James Caan and Robert
Duvall.
Their testosterone-fueled friendship comes
to an abrupt end when Duvall double-crosses
Caan and leaves him for dead.
Caan's rehabilitation involves intense martial
arts training, which serves him well when
he hits the revenge trail to stop an assassin
from killing a Taiwanese politician.
This doesn't sit well with Duvall, who summons
a small army of ninja to finish the job.
But Peckinpah's ninja are no more effective
than standard issue henchmen, falling hard
to a guy with a cane, a dumpy Burt Young,
a middle-aged diplomat and his daughter, and
a machine gun-toting Bo Hopkins.
According to the martial arts compendium These
Fists Break Bricks, the early 1980s ninja
were thriving on TV, in best-selling books,
and even in perfume.
The time was right for a Hollywood ninja movie,
and Mike Stone thought it would be his ticket
to stardom.
Stone, a karate champion and instructor, pitched
a ninja movie called Dance of Death to The
Cannon Group — the movie factory that would
be responsible for many of Chuck Norris's
action titles.
With Stone signed on as both star and scriptwriter,
the producers were hoping to beat 20th Century
Fox's adaptation of Eric Van Lustbader's The
Ninja to theaters.
They didn't need to worry — that production
fell into developmental hell — but they
soon faced their own problems with the movie
that would become 1981's Enter the Ninja.
Producer Menahem Golan reportedly arrived
on set and fired the director, crew, and Stone
as leading man.
As Stone said in The Cannon Film Guide Volume
II,
Golan stepped in as director and hired Italian
actor Franco Nero to replace Stone.
"Gentlemen.
Let's be reasonable.
Why don't we talk?"
Golan would eventually walk back his decision
somewhat, rehiring Stone as fight coordinator
and as Nero's stunt double.
He allowed Stone to hire his own stuntmen,
including a Japanese kendo and judo champ
named Sho Kosugi.
Kosugi would also play one of the film's bad
guys — a performance that made him the face
of ninja throughout the 1980s.
Throughout the 80s, Sho Kosugi was an on-screen
murder machine, laying waste to every bad
guy who dared to cross his path.
One of his most popular movies during this
period was 1985's Pray for Death.
That was the best you could hope for from
Sho: that he'd kill you quickly.
That image contrasted heavily with Kosugi's
real life as a hard-working family man with
a healthy skepticism about his status as an
action hero.
Though his on-screen characters made him exceptionally
popular, his legacy was ultimately cemented
as the first Japanese actor to top-bill an
American action movie.
While he had been elevated from the bad guy
in Enter the Ninja to the hero in Revenge
of the Ninja, he was dismissive of the loopy
Ninja III: The Domination and left the Cannon
Group over a contract dispute.
After Pray for Death earned an X rating, he
requested cuts to ensure that younger fans
could see it.
When the national box office returns for ninja
movies cooled off, Kosugi hosted the Ninja
Theater VHS series and eventually returned
to Japan, where he found new fame on television.
In 2009, the Wachowskis paid tribute to his
early screen days by casting him as the villain
in Ninja Assassin.
Though The Cannon Group lost Sho Kosugi, they
still saw money to be made in the shuriken
and katana business.
As noted in These Fist Break Bricks, the company
pre-sold American Ninja as a vehicle for Chuck Norris.
They had to go looking for a new action star,
though, as Norris wasn't interested in the project.
Enter Michael Dudikoff, a model-turned-actor
who often played affable boyfriends and best
pals in movies and on television.
"Veal…
Par…
What's this word?"
"It's Parmesan."
Director Sam Firstenberg was instantly smitten
with Dudikoff, recalling to KungFuMagazine.com,
What Dudikoff lacked was the necessary martial
arts skills.
He knew some, but he wasn't entirely believable
as someone who could fight multiple ninja
at once or jump out of a helicopter.
Thankfully, the producers still had Mike Stone
on hand to choreograph the fights and help
Dudikoff achieve ninja-level prowess.
It certainly didn't hurt that he was paired
up on-screen with Steve James, a brawny real-life
martial artist.
Dudikoff would play Joe Armstrong in two of
the three sequels, sharing lead billing with
actor David Bradley on American Ninja 4.
Let's say it's 1982, and you're an independent
distributor with a sizable catalog of martial
arts movies.
Audiences aren't lining up for these titles
like they used to — not like the new crop
of ninja flicks cleaning up in theaters and
on home video.
So, being the enterprising type, you snip
off the title cards from a handful of your
movies and stitch on new ones that prominently
feature ninja.
The fact that your movies have little or nothing
to do with ninja, well, that's beside the point.
According to a 1986 New York Daily News interview
with Rod Hurley, Vice President of Master Arts Video,
One of the more amusing examples includes
1982's Shaolin Prince.
When it finally arrived on American VHS, it
bore the title Death Mask of the Ninja, despite
no ninja being in the film.
The 1978 period action drama Heroes of the
East features Chinese and Japanese martial
arts, but its real concern is a broken marriage.
Nevertheless, it was renamed numerous times,
given titles such as Shaolin Challenges Ninja,
Challenge of the Ninja, and Shaolin vs. Ninja.
When a film subgenre runs out of gas, one
of the most common ways for producers to retain
fan interest is to fold elements of other
genres into their titles.
This cross-pollination has resulted in some
inspired hybrids and some genuine oddities,
and ninja movies are no exception.
"Curses!
Get 'em, boys!"
During this period, fans would stumble across
mutations like 1989's Robot Ninja, a no-budget
comedy about a comic book artist fighting
crime.
Ninja Academy, from the same year, applied
the Police Academy formula to a pair of rival
ninja schools populated by misanthropic weirdos.
Of course, the hands-down winner for most
bizarre ninja-hybrid movie might just be 1984's
Ninja III: The Domination.
Intended as another sequel to Enter the Ninja,
the film takes an unexpected turn into the supernatural.
Lucinda Dickey is an aerobics instructor possessed
by the spirit of an evil ninja.
James Hong is an exorcist who fails to remove
the spirit, which prompts — who else?
— Sho Kosugi to step in.
Floating swords, lycra bodysuits, and mind
control all combine into a truly absurd experience.
While it's unlikely that the American-made
ninja movies of the 1980s will ever be described
as classics, even the worst Cannon Group titles
can appear worthy of the Criterion Collection
when compared to the films of Hong Kong's
Godfrey Ho.
He flooded international markets with hundreds
of cheaply made, nonsensical ninja movies
during the 1980s and 1990s.
"Alright, you better come out now."
"Oh, I think we better do as he says."
After catching wind of Enter the Ninja and
wanting his own Franco Nero for his ninja
projects, Ho would hire American actor Richard
Harrison — a star of spaghetti Westerns.
However, Ho didn't seem to care that Harrison
didn't know martial arts.
He also didn't care that the props and sets
were dollar-store quality, or that the movies'
dialogue was seemingly endless verbal loops
on ninja empires.
Ho simply hid his stunt players behind hoods
and masks, and threw in plenty of gunplay
and smoke bombs to hide the seams.
But what set Ho's movies apart from other
low-budget martial arts titles of the era
was his practice of recycling footage from
one film to create dozens of others.
Scenes of Harrison shot for one movie would
turn up in several other Ho titles, and Harrison
later claimed that Ho's movies caused him
to quit acting completely.
When Ho exhausted his footage of Harrison,
he bought movies from other Asian markets
and dissected them for more Frankenstein creations.
Quality — or lack thereof — didn't stop
Ho until he supposedly retired in the early
2000s to become a film teacher, of all things.
In the 1980s, ninja exploitation films wreaked
low-budget havoc across international screens
in the Philippines, Hong Kong, Turkey, and
even India.
But one probably wouldn't expect a ninja movie
to come from Sweden.
However, the Scandinavian country produced
a small handful of homegrown ninja titles
in the late 80s, with the best known to international
audiences being 1984's The Ninja Mission.
"Listen Mason, and listen good.
You're to take the ninja into Russia, and
get Markov out."
A hopelessly convoluted and astonishingly
gory thriller that pits a CIA-backed team
of Swedish ninja against Soviet forces that
hold a defecting Russian scientist hostage.
Bo F. Munthe — the self-described Grandfather
of European Ninjutsu — co-stars as a member
of the ninja team, whose martial arts skills
could be charitably described as rudimentary.
However, their ability to kill bad guys in
as messy a manner as possible is top-notch.
Director Mats Helge Olsson had previously
made headlines in the early 80s for producing
the historical epic Sweden for the Swedes,
which landed him in prison for accounting misdeeds.
He rebounded with the international theatrical
and VHS sales for The Ninja Mission, which
he followed with a slew of other action titles
— each one as technically inept, yet enthusiastically
made as the next.
The VHS boom wasn't just a fresh revenue source
for theatrical movies, old and new.
It also provided aspiring filmmakers a chance
to get their homemade productions out into
the world.
These backyard auteurs typically focused on
the genres that attracted the widest viewership
— so if you owned a headband and a rubber
throwing star, this was your chance to be
in the ninja movie business.
Some of the best-known, or notorious, homegrown
ninja titles included Justice, Ninja Style
— a $12,000 actioner by St. Louis detective-turned-filmmaker
Ron White — and L.A. Streetfighters, where
a forty-something former Bruce Lee clone plays
a high schooler battling drug dealers.
But L.A. Streetfighters director Richard Park
Woo-sang also oversaw another amateur ninja
picture, Miami Connection, that inexplicably
found an enthusiastic audience — three decades
after its original release.
According to Park, after seeing an interview
with taekwondo studio owner Master Y.K.
Kim on a South Korean talk show, Park pitched
him on making a martial arts movie.
Kim recruited his students as cast members,
borrowed money from friends, and even mortgaged
his school to fund the movie.
However, distributors took one look at its
plot — a mishmash of non-sequiturs about
a rock band running afoul of drug-dealing
ninja — and advised Kim to just throw it away.
Flash forward to 2009, when Alamo Drafthouse
programmer Zach Carlson bought the film on
eBay and screened a reel for audiences at
their Austin, Texas location.
Rapturous response led to festival dates,
leaving Kim baffled, delighted, and ready
to make more movies.
He told Weekly,
Taiwanese actor John Liu earned a following
for his superhuman high kicks in low-budget
Hong Kong and Taiwanese kung fu movies during
the 1970s.
But as the old joke goes, what he really wanted
to do was direct.
In the 1980s, he established his own microbudget
production company and wrote, produced, directed,
and starred in four nearly incoherent martial
arts movies.
The last of these, New York Ninja, began filming
in 1984 but was abandoned after its distributor
filed for bankruptcy.
This drove Liu to give up filmmaking and return
to Paris to oversee his own martial arts studio.
"You can't beat me.
I'm immortal."
Flash-forward three decades, and the film
preservation and home video distributor Vinegar
Syndrome locates the surviving elements, but
no script or storyboards.
When Liu declined to complete the movie, editor
Kurtis M. Spieler painstakingly assembled
the footage into a semi-coherent storyline,
earning himself credit as the film's Re-Director.
After corralling several cult actors to dub
the on-screen characters, New York Ninja played
the film festival circuit in 2021, eventually
receiving a national release.
As for the finished product?
Well, seeing really is believing.
Audiences may not fully accept the sight of
a ninja vigilante patrolling New York City
— occasionally on roller skates — in search
of the cartoonish gang members who killed
his wife.
A radioactive villain called the Plutonium
Man and an army of grade school ninja fans
also factor into the mix, which wobbles and
bops to a new '80s-synth-style score by Voyag3r.
Though ninja appeared to be unstoppable on-screen,
their appeal eventually waned.
While remaining a popular draw on the home
video market, theatrical returns began to
dwindle as the 80s drew to a close.
A wave of negative press started, about how
ninja led to real-life crime, including a
highly-publicized 1984 home invasion of actress/director
Penny Marshall.
Profit-minded producers began shifting away
from ninja, wi th films like 1985's No Retreat,
No Surrender elevating the marquee status
of kickboxing, a more aggressive combat sport
than ninjutsu, with less spirituality.
With the help of the energetic Belgian martial
artist and actor Jean-Claude Van Damme, kickboxing
and mixed martial arts came to dominate the
American action scene, introducing a host
of new movie stars.
These ranged from Steven Seagal and Bruce
Lee's son, Brandon, to direct-to-video players
like Billy Blanks, Don "The Dragon" Wilson,
and Cynthia Rothrock.